we have a clip here from the stand-up
special and maybe I should just show it
first I I think you know what Kannan let
me set it up a little bit actually if I
can that's the perfect thing to do when
you're about to set up an important clip
you know let me set it up for a second
feel like it needs a tiny bit of setup
in this clip I'm talking about how
people talk crazy during sex and that I
have tried this it doesn't really work
for me but I did make it I find that the
truth gets in the way you know like I'll
be like oh my god your penis is so oh no
it's a shadow right right now you can go
and now this is okay so this is as
opposed to talking during sex this is
what you've been trying let's take a
look I like to talk crazy right after
sex things have calmed down a beat get
right in his face real quiet what do you
think would happen if I went on down to
the hospital and got a rape exam right
you think they'd find your semen all
over and inside my boyfriend is foreign
so then I get like really nose to nose
with him and go you like number one and
what you don't worry about it
it's important to us that we're number
one juvenile diabetes is this something
you've really tried is this do you joke
around in a sensual situation I will
tell you something I asked Michael if it
was okay that I revealed to these things
your boyfriend Michael Sheen yes my
on-again off-again lover Michael Sheen
terrific actor wonderful man yes he said
you can absolutely talk about it because
no one would believe that you really say
this after sex and so he let me do it
but I do really I get verbal tics I feel
like that section that clip is very Todd
berry and performance mmm-hmm like why
don't you go ahead and take a lot back
right you're taking it down real low
it's very Todd berry and in that time
berry vein I too have verbal tics in
real life you do yeah like what like all
the things I said in that was close
those aren't verbal tics sanity
yeah like Todd will go like apologize
don't know where exactly but these are
mine
you